Now let's go back to the two pathways activated during stress response. The
second pathway that's responsible for our stress response, is the hypothalamus
pituitary adrenal axis, or HPA access, for short. When we're experiencing our
stressful emotional response to a stressor our hypothalamus releases something
called the corticotropin releasing factor or CRF for short. Then like a domino
effect, this causes the pitutary gland to release adrenocorticotropic hormone,
ACTH for short, which then causes the adrenal gland to secrete cortisol.
Cortisol is a major gluccocorticoid produced in humans. Which is commonly
called the stress hormone. This secretes from hypothalamus to pituitary gland
to adrenal gland is why it's called the HPA axis, H P A.